don't forget they also put a huge
spoiler on the back of the car for no
reason i did too super spooky
they're like hey the car got shot a few
times this is a great time to add an
even bigger sport
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
i found something that y'all
you know it took me long enough to find
this but nick has it
what is it oh was it a fossil nick
sean what's up dude don't say nick so it
almost sounds racial oh yeah
yeah it was very yeah it sounded like
i'm using a hard r what is that
what is that what is that right that
does
not look like that doesn't look like it
it doesn't look like you though oh that
doesn't look like me
that's me that looks like george mason
with a [ __ ] degree that's no that's
me that's chappelle that ain't you bro
and where you got that i gave him
another one
watch this that's me and my mama i don't
know that's
me photoshop is [ __ ] yeah that looks
like my buddy i went to high school with
dog but not you
no that's me is that a halloween party
yeah why is it so dark outside what's
that gold dust too there's a bunch of
white people in the background
yeah man this don't look like a real
graduation
yeah photoshop it's a picture i know
what i did when i did it because i did
it
all right where'd you graduate from
popeyes
what is that orange neck thing you got
on man that's pop
yellow this is high school or college so
that's high school so i had to go to
i look like i technically i technically
didn't graduate from that school
yeah no no no you got to listen
so i had to go to like a bad kids school
like the secondary school where like
oh yeah if you get kicked out or
whatever you go you go there
yeah but they they were like hey you can
walk at
whatever school you want to walk at
that's in your uh area
so i chose so so they let me walk and uh
so i didn't graduate from that school
sounds complicated
yeah look bruh but to be part of
ceremony let me be part of the ceremony
so that's what
the other kids like who the [ __ ] is this
yeah this is this random kid walking
with him i ain't never seen him around
walking down the stage and [ __ ] well
first of all look at that
little ass diploma i never even seen it
that little is that the freaking one you
put in your uh that you put in your
wallet look at that little ass diploma
that's a real difference is it blurred
out
yeah sure it almost looks like a really
bad yes
does that not look like me no nope
really yeah your torso looks super long
too and you look super tall torso
oh dude you look tall yeah you look real
tall like trans almost a little bit
but with no wig and look at you went
full training
like a woman that went to a man you know
you looked a little bit like dennis
rodman's son there oh yeah
there's a little rock what does his son
look like i don't know i see rod has the
kids
oh you see rodney mouth the mouth the
mouth yeah
that is me them girls in the back don't
give a [ __ ] because they don't know who
you are
ain't nobody know who you are no one
know you are
i'll tell you that's what some dude told
me in oklahoma
there was a there was i did the hard
rock out there
and they said sold out so i was like
feeling myself
and then there's a tornado warning and
they're like you got to start the show
i was like you sold out bro and i and he
he gives me the check ahead of time i
said
oh no i hit the bonus man because sold
out so you got and goes
in in front of my opener and stuff
because let me talk to my office all
right
i'm going to office down goes here's the
problem you didn't sell out young man
his promise ain't nobody know who you
are around here nobody know who you are
because i'm sure in la new york they
know you around here we don't know who
you are
he was blind like you had to we're going
to have you back
but you you sure as hell didn't sell
this thing out it was about 200 people
out there
and there was a tornado warning so
there's about 50 people out there
i said please don't make me go out there
man that giant arena and perform
as i could just do in the green room he
goes that's not the way we operate young
man
so you can go out there and do a good
show when you have your back damn and
hopefully some people know who y'all
[Music]
and that's wild man and the man how old
was the man that said it he was older he
goes we've had everybody in here
yeah he goes don't feel frederick
douglass i know right here
so we had everybody in here yeah we had
everybody we had everybody here
biatha frederick douglass ain't nobody
know who you are
christopher columbus's son we've had
everybody come through here what was the
place
uh hard rock casino in uh oklahoma
oh ain't nobody know who you are there's
tornado warnings there was
nine people in the ground bro y'all are
[ __ ] stupid
oh how you feeling after that [ __ ]
after that spicy chip dog
this is the text i get from theo so we
we ate those spicy [ __ ]
super [ __ ] super the text i get from
these are the texts i get from him
he put uh he put a picture of him crying
he said that chip making me poop doug
and he goes making me poop
hot and i said i'm holding mine in i
don't need those problems right now
and he put uh it's so hot and i said
it's all right man i said my girl wants
to try when she said we're a bunch of
[ __ ]
because she saw us crying on the episode
and uh i said she wants one so
we're going to order some i looked this
woman in the eye i said
[ __ ] he put no bro my poop's hot
you're not feeling hot i woke up at two
in the morning i i lost like an hour and
a half of sleep yeah
i was on the toilet and it was it was
hot i didn't have any problems dog you
know what [ __ ] my world up the most
i was having to pour milk onto my butt
that's how hot it was
it got lost in translation i think but
that the milk that theo drank
i brought so people could drink it but i
forgot it in my car and it was
it was in there for like an hour and a
half no that didn't get lost in
translation because when you put it down
you went hey this is lukewarm it's been
my car but here's some mountains i was
not mike so i don't know if the people
at home
got it but uh yeah but theo nonetheless
drank about half
half that i had a sip of it it was
disgusting
did it help did it help you drank a lot
of it did it help i don't know if it
helped
anything it definitely gave me something
to do for a few seconds
i guess the real challenge people were
saying is you you got to eat the chip
and like
chew it like chappelle did and then you
gotta not drink water that's the real
challenge
oh yep cat didn't seem to have a problem
with it you think you're [ __ ] cool
yeah you're a bunch of [ __ ] but
uh no i needed water for that you were
sweating no
i wasn't sweating but it hurt like your
mouth what do you know in your life cat
i feel like you never tell us anything
huh i don't really do what i don't know
i don't really do much honestly well
tell us about that
uh my sister lives with me i'm getting
ready to move i have no
idea where to go why are you moving just
my lease is up i don't really want to be
in that area anymore i like to move
around from
like different parts of la to see
like the different areas because i feel
like i only ever stay
within like a 10 mile radius of me so
we're
not going to work right now i'm looking
i'd rather not say
i'd rather not say but i lived in
downtown what's hollywood right
no i used to work in west hollywood i
used to live in um
i lived in downtown i lived in south
central
i lived in south central i went to usc
that's why so the school was right there
so i didn't really have a choice by
watts right uh
not really um it's closer to like the
outskirts of
downtown l.a so you're trying to get
near the water
maybe i like the valley the valley or
somewhere closer to the water
yep come on down there don't worry now
look i'll tell you guys this man
if i could i would take my nuts out of
here
[Laughter]
divide them up amongst you guys y'all
[ __ ] freaks let's go to this video
nick
uh so a couple weeks ago we asked for
delivery driver submissions because we
have so many that watch
and we got we got a lot they're out in
the road listening to us
he's a beautiful guy that's alan from
ohio
i'm a half filipino fedex driver so i
feel like the show is built for me
love listening to the show every friday
keep it
up thanks for getting helping me get
through quarantine i just got a quick
debate club for you
i'm getting married next week and my
fiancee's family and my family
have a difference of opinion on who's
better
elton john or billy joel let me know
what you think
gang gang buzz buzz buzz buzz young man
that's a tough one he does look like
allen joe bam bring up pick a pitcher
island joe man yeah who is this and your
man's fighting i don't know what i i
think he said the dang model sometimes
when joe ban is in the ring i feel like
he should be one of the ring
girls honestly you get an erection when
he's fighting
no dude yeah [ __ ] no i don't
i mean i will admit i'm a stone cold
model sometimes look at his instagram
late at night though
but no uh just a look but no yeah just a
look man just passing by
yeah but dang that's a good call though
because
yeah you like dang man that boy bodied
up now
he has a fight too coming up does he
yeah he's pretty good
yeah he's good uh he's hard man
uh what is it he's a little no elton
john or billy joel
versace versace versace oh he really
does model yeah legit model oh
i think ford yeah yeah that's where it
comes from you didn't know that
oh yeah damn i just thought dude if i
was just good looking i wouldn't let
people be
beat on me you know beating on you for
being ugly oh i'm already ugly
yeah i beat on myself me dude
late at night beating that meat ugh
brenden
kids listen to this show man kids that
probably are prepubescent man
jesus yeah he's a straight-up model dog
but uh billy joel or elton john
you said that did you already talk about
him john my mom's big elton john fence
i'll go ellen john okay
y'all liking that gay fella huh that
tiny dancer
that tiny dancer oh time dancer is good
bring him a picture of the other guy
who's the other guy paul simon you know
because
i like paul simon myself billy jones
ain't [ __ ] man
oh come on now oh billy joel did
crocodile rock or something didn't he
yeah
that eliminated him right there for me
he did a new york state of mind i really
like that song
he just looks like an both of them look
like [ __ ] they do
that's fair ellen john got kids
yeah he's got a couple right and step
brothers horatio sans
plays the lead man the front man in a
billy joel cover band but they only
played
late 80s billy joel and if you request
earlier in that oh yeah
so i would say probably i like uh
you know what i like man i realized the
other day man uh
men no
god damn time you realize that dude if i
was dating a man bro i would freaking
know
yeah you're right yeah if i was gay i
would know dog
i don't know sometimes you just hit you
nah man
but it would have hit me it would have
been amazing again butcherbox was really
a dick
[Laughter]
you are gross brendon you are a girl i'm
an elm john fan dog
no you're not yeah i am i'm a poster of
them you have what a drawing of them
even nothing
yeah i'll draw them right now you can't
draw elton john right now
yeah i could let's get some
i'm going old elton john too with the
glasses the hat
the get up dicks on his shoulder dude
you can't draw
yeah i can first of all i'm sorry if you
can
it's not going to get you any street
credit anywhere maybe outside of san
fran dude
go get your elton john's sketch on you
right you make millions out there
you like elton john huh yeah he's good
oh man you pandering bro give me this
[ __ ] give me something too i'll draw a
damn melting john you freak
do you guys want a reference photo or
just off the dome oh
phil collins i like phil collins
and i also went to high school with a
fella named phil collins dude yeah
i don't believe that and he had early
onset uh
alzheimer's i think or something or his
hair turned gray early remember
oh he did yeah i mean what's going on
whatever that is that is that
alzheimer's no what is it uh i don't
think so i don't think that's what it is
i don't know nothing man what is uh in
the air tonight about it's
something crazy i can feel it coming do
we know what it's about yeah what is it
about
i thought it was something like it's
about cocaine
he wrote it about
maybe it's not about anything crazy i'm
excited to see these pictures though
yeah i know well brilliant yeah brenda
can draw though
yeah i like elton john because the
eminem stan he did that at the grammys
and like he showed everybody that eminem
wasn't a bigot because
they hugged oh yeah when he was like
that's all it is yeah let's go
give a [ __ ] a hug that's all it
is
and then he also did uh in the air
tonight
on lion king yeah he did i
yeah that's right and he did tarzan
can you feel the love tonight oh that
was filled out one more you phil collins
i was talking about aunt john oh okay
quick sketch of elton john that's good
damn that's pretty good
you curse all the time yeah i do okay
yeah well your son's gonna watch us i
got sailor's mouth doug
this is mine right here and that's what
y'all get cause y'all hoes bro
and i'm sorry for being rude to you guys
today man but you guys are [ __ ] hoes
what's a match
huh nuts everything
that reminds me of a whole gathering
sean connery on uh the snl
jeopardies like you just always have
some messages
suck at your back so let me see yours
bro are you hiding the art ability dude
that's pretty damn good dude i didn't
have about two
seconds dawg you took way too long
that looks like smoke my nuts still
smoke my natch dog
that looks like christopher columbus
nerdy brother dude ronnie you grew up
with
that looks like ronnie columbus dude bro
you could never find america if you were
in a boat dude
not a chance bro they got gps now you're
[ __ ] delinquent i'm talking about 2
000 years ago when christopher columbus
is here you idiot i would find it and
lie like he did
yeah right you can pretend like it's
india yeah look into it
not sneeze on him kill everybody look
into it yeah look into that boy
[Laughter]
dog how much meat can you fit in your
mouth oh
not as much as you you'd be surprised
dog
you'd be surprised but you just won't
put any meat in your mouth you want the
best meat possible i'm talking about
highly sustainable tasty meat i'm
talking about free range organic chicken
100
grass-fed finished beef all right
today's sponsor butcher box bleaching
everyone deserves high quality meat just
not theo or myself
every month butcher box ships and
curated selection of high quality meats
right to your door dude i'm talking nine
to 11 pounds of straight up
tasty meat bro i know what you're
talking about they got organic chicken
they got heritage pork man we're talking
about pork that
is you know it's you know some history
too yeah some history to it somebody's
got a degree in its family like this
ain't no just
pork voted a few times yeah this pork
has been through some things
wild caught alaskan salmon
i mean this is salmon that's been out
there for years people couldn't catch it
bam they caught it
your suburb salmon man we're talking
about real wild things
nitrate-free bacon a lot of people
eating bacon and suddenly your wife
sprouts a mustache bro we ain't doing
all of that yeah man butcher box the
most affordable convenient way to get
healthy humanely raised
meat with butcher box you get the
highest quality meat around for just six
dollars a meal
all right and right now butcher box is
offering you guys two lobster tails
two fleming youngs for free in the first
box that's two
tails from the lobster two fillets from
them cows
for free in your first box go to
butcherbox.com
kats that's butcherbox.com k-a-t-s
get the free lobsters get the free
filets do it right
do you do your family a damn justice and
get the meat from them
look here's the thing man you get so
much hair coming out of your body you
don't know what to do some people call
the police some people
you know some people some people take
their life bro some people do you know
i'm sick of shame with these dull blades
it's exhausting and then
my boy harry came along and said guess
what we got the sharpest blades
ever got that shot they're not charging
more for this man
harry's new sharper blades are still as
low as ever we're talking two dollars
each two dollars each of blaze yes you
can find harry's new sharper blades in a
big box
drug grocery stores near you if you like
to shop online new us
customers can redeem a trial offer of
harry's new sharper blades by going to
harrys.com
k-a-t-s we've got a special deal for you
k-a-t-s quit having hair everywhere
harry owns a german factory that's been
honing razor blades for a hundred years
100 percent quality guaranteed at
harry's doc
of course yes harry's available wherever
you shop you can get here sharpest
blades ever
big box drug grocery stores near you
just head on over the grooming aisle
if you like to shop online we got some
for your new u.s
customers can redeem harry's trial set
at harrys.com
cats do it right if you have a problem
you'll get a five blade razor featuring
the new sharper blades
a weighted handle foaming shave gel with
alloy
and travel cover to protect your blade
when you're on the go just go to harry's
dot com slash cats and redeem your trial
effort today oh god
i'm gone running to the altar like a
track style
here comes a guy right here who's trying
to be like me
boys been seeing a little bit too much
of that uh
purple turtle or that brown cow
oh but it's time for the blue eagle baby
salute got a bait club for you here
either that river flipping
it seems nice or that cold waterfall
dipping
this guy's sexual huh
that seems nice this looks like a herbal
essence commercial
gang gang
buzz he didn't know what to say
but he covered it pretty well yeah he
did usps
doug shout out to usps man you know the
workers they're good people man they get
people out there hustling
get in the mail doing this and doing
that you know when i was growing up they
had a fella and he would
bring the mailbox and he would do all
the uh
he would open all of the perfume samples
and smell them all bro he had some
condition or something
you know yeah so you get your perfume
samples and they'd already been smelled
you know
remember how they used to have their
perfume samples yeah every now and then
you get a little freaking hit of noir or
something i'd save it for the dance when
i had a school dance hell yeah
i put that [ __ ] under my little uh know
when to use it son i had like this metal
like thing you put your clothes on i'd
slide it under there and then
when it was time for the dance i'd get
that thing out you know
but he kept using them all so they'd
come and be like oh damn this dude
smells great but
i smell like [ __ ] this dude's harboring
all the good smell that's
trying to come through the neighborhood
through the u.s postal system but i'll
say this man there's no shittier system
going on in america right now than the
u.s postal system
hey dog why you set him up just to bring
him down
i love the workers because of because
the voting [ __ ]
no no he's a great this guy's a great
guy man and i wish him long prosperity
we don't know him but yeah you know and
i love y'all's movie too what's the one
with kevin costner
you got man postman
um and but i'm telling you the truth
brother
yeah and that is that
oh [ __ ] man what's up are they [ __ ]
up or something no not at all what can
brown do for you [ __ ]
they i mean look you mail something on a
tuesday bruh it gets there next year dog
you know you don't know when something's
getting there true
they'll send them a letter says hey your
letter's coming but they
but they won't even get the ladder dog
i'm just saying it's become
a shoddily reliable system
and that's why amazon took out that's
why i mean u.s post system could be
amazon man
nah not really they don't have the
infrastructure but they could have over
all of this time they're just screwing
around
and they're violent you get into the
regular place they violently say hey
here's my mail card see if my mail is
coming to lady leave go on vacation
you be violent too if you always worry
about dogs and [ __ ]
they're doing the lord's work man pit
bulls chasing them
rottweilers okay we're just trying to
drop off your shitty porno magazines
just download it you gotta get it the
physical yeah i feel like the paper dog
i like old school and i can't even
download it anymore i have too many
blockers on my on my electronics
literally did you block your calculator
too huh oh yeah that calculator
uh deleted that yeah okay um but
it's tough man oh but his his uh king
you're stinging it was uh waterfalls or
jumping in that
cold river or yeah yeah rivers
rivers are waterfalls it was a cool
video who cares about his topic
right yeah they're both good dog i like
to go down that river lazy boys when i
was young
these people was more wild though
remember there was a time when people
were sh
at the postal place were shooting up the
office remember that yeah it seemed like
every other day for a little bit there
and suddenly you know all the heavy
hitters brought the bad boys out of the
usps
they are either locked up or they're
gone or they join antifa yeah you got
this guy he's more of a hippie kind of
relaxation
nature you know nature male boy you know
i miss those old school bad boys dude
you know what i'm saying dude come in
with a stamp you know a book
of stamps and a book in the book of
mormon bro
you know look at stamps from book of
mormon yeah book of eli
yeah a book of samson a book of eli
thank you nick and i'm gonna repeat your
jokes because that's how we do it on
here
yeah you would roll in with just uh uh
you know i'm i'll miss the old guys with
the weapon if that guy would have
flashed a weapon in the vehicle
i'm in wait wait can any of you guys
flip into the water
how you flipping the water yeah yeah
yeah euthea
no front flip in a water i can i can if
i want to
[Laughter]
but yeah i don't want to
i gotta get new buzzers for you guys
next next show i promise new buzzers
brand new who's this little zz top fella
what up brandon what up theo what's
going on king of the steam crew
this is mark you guys asked for driver
submissions and i
are one but today yeah
yeah i'm shooting my shot you see when
brenda first started the thick boy bike
club it got me motivated
so i started riding and i lost
20 pounds oh it felt great so i kept on
riding
and then i lost 25 pounds felt even
better so i kept on riding before i knew
it
i had ridden 1700 plus miles and lost
over 30 pounds this summer and i feel
fantastic so to treat myself i'm
entering my first race
the indiana gravel gravel it's a 100k
race november 28th and today the shot
that i miss
that i am shooting is for
thick boy bike club to sponsor me on
that race
to get me out of the morning fresh
looking clean
and uh just doing what we do baby out
there riding and representing that
thickness
i want to be your on-the-ground
ambassador come out what up
anyway hey just shout out to all you
guys man i listen to everything you guys
do and uh i just appreciate everything
and thanks
keep it rocking gang gang gang bro
say no more fam uh send nick your
address and i'll send you a little gift
box before your race son
no he don't want to get box burning he
wants you to cover the feed they got to
want a damn
you don't wanna scarf dude okay that's
what he said he wants the gear he said
he wants to rock the gear dog
didn't he say he wants you to sponsor
him right yeah he wants to sponsor him
see what he wants nick i thought he said
follow up with him
you're talking about like getting some
gear too yeah yeah i'll send them some
gear
but what i'm saying you got to pay the
entrance fee for the man and man lost
30. the man lost 30 thick ass all right
i'll do that man
get the info nick s my
leprechaun you figure it out dude that
looks like willy wonka bro
and that was that was mark ridge and uh
shout out one take those
that was good and i want to go back and
say this too to the postal man
hate on him yeah be easy man my best
friend his family is all postal i love
look dude
you keep saying that and then you [ __ ]
on it
you don't love him you have a deep
hatred for him obviously he doesn't like
their operation
i am he likes the people i get my
[ __ ] mail all the time what's wrong
with you dog your problem is you bounce
around all the goddamn time well the
problem
in one spot a lot of it is is i also
want to say it's los
angeles based mail you send a mail they
don't get it
you go over to the mailbox in the park
and the guys you know
two homeless dudes have been using it to
raise bees in it you know
and there's nothing they can do the city
can't touch it they're like oh we got to
let them do it
we got to wait till the bees leave
naturally before we can use it for mail
again i'm not worried about the [ __ ]
mail someone keeps taking my
ups and amazon packages though that's
what you got to worry about
mm-hmm you ordered some nice [ __ ] and
somebody's stealing your package they
just busted a guy he'd been he worked
for uh
amazon and he was just taking all this
up to his house yeah i got these stupid
[ __ ] on video even
mm-hmm and the cops came over like
there's not much we can do
yep really yep ring cam
i got him get a uh bow and arrows yep
i'll shoot that [ __ ] right in
the butt dog
get a bow and arrows dude hit somebody
in that femur yep what's this
kid talking about you could you could
just order a bunch of packages for a
couple days
wait out there that'd be fun shoot them
yeah or you could buy the
um what is it the confetti gun that like
when you open it up after they try to
steal a package it explodes everywhere
yeah
yeah if you were a clown yeah
i don't know where to get those cats so
if you see some fly ass ups worker in a
supreme hat let me know man
that's my [ __ ] so he's obviously
filipino yeah
dude i'm just saying bro i respect the
male people i used to go sleep over my
buddy jeff salvia's house they had a
[ __ ] gas leak over there his dad did
the mail
and we would put all kind of stuff in
his mailbag we would open mail
you know we'd be over there that's
illegal
that's a that's a felony that's a felony
bro
dude he left his mail back on the door
well no he lived there
and he was taking a [ __ ] break and
you delinquent start going through
people's mail
which is a federal crime sir y'all
haters bro
okay y'all haters dude shout out to all
the grandmothers who sent those two
dollar bills
today grandsons man we had
bank around then dude i was buying runs
candy every day
i'd be rolling up with those two dollar
bills dude
and it'd be like oh yeah i'd even
sometimes i would open it instead of
having a wallet i just have one of the
christmas cards and i'll just have all
the money and
stacked in there damn we were living
large man it was good times brought gas
leaks in the u.s postal system i get it
i'll tell you what's not funny uh
brendan
will you stop talking to me
please uh i'll try to help i'm trying to
be by myself for a minute i know i'm
trying to help you out though
i know i know you got some wiener
problems it's not
helping well don't i can't help but i'll
tell you hymns can help
i can't help but hams can well i mean
the company hems
look i do not want to hear from some man
about my wiener
yeah hymns is a company dog we talking
people thought
old dudes suffered with eddie i got a
very wiener baby
wake your wiener up dog on that
wienerbad boy
who is wieners man
with licensed physicians dog i'm talking
all you do is answer quick few questions
next thing you know
your dick's working he's a bad winner
bad winner and he's coming for you bad
winner
try him today by starting with a free
online visit go to for hims.com
kats5 for hims.com
kats 5. daddy got that soft hit
prescription stick are subject to
medical provider approval and require an
online conversation with a medical
provider who determines which decision
is appropriate
see website for full detail and safer
information that's for hims.com
five he limp he limp
get it hit it nick you gotta love it vo
thorn schwinn
bribe i got a debate club for you first
i gotta clear up some air but a lot of
talk about these delivery boys
ups usps fedex [ __ ] all them boys
i'm talking about them heavy hitters
them 10 speed splitters boy
we talking about them [ __ ] big
packages
that bad baby weighs 49 000 pounds [ __ ]
them three pound packages
leads me to my debate club you're gonna
go in the truck stop
probably dirty as [ __ ] [ __ ] all over the
toilet seat you're gonna wipe it off
with the tp
or you're gonna use that port of john
that job johnny boy you know what i'm
talking about
with the hand sanitizer squirt a little
bit on the tp and wipe off the toilet
seat
let me know what you boys think or you
could just take a [ __ ] in the back of
the truck in the garbage can like i've
had to do a couple times not proud of it
trucks boy i like this dude's energy
yeah
that job johnny dude what are you using
brendan
man my my family's truck driver's dog so
we i've had to shin the back myself a
few times when i was a kid yeah i used
to go on the jo
the voyages with him my uncle's still
delivering right now to this day
oh for real denver to la's his track
amen bro
hey man we used to play dirty ernie do
where somebody would like
you would put your feet on the dock by
the river you know and
somebody would hold you off like you
hold your arms so say if you were
holding me i'd be like this
and then whoever's getting held off
defecates out into the water yeah
that's not gay [ __ ] doug your friend
interlocking fingers while everyone
and what's the game the game here's the
game
well now that i think about the game
it's a little questionable
but so you go as much as you can yeah
and then whenever your buddy wants to he
can let you go
it's not that big of a game really but
dog one time me and my brother worked
for a
it's a real time it's a vibe i feel you
we worked that all seasons it was rental
[ __ ]
my brother drive the big rig and i just
chill in the seat right
yeah it's called being lazy dude oh my
super that's why i got fired
but so we'd drop off like party supplies
chairs all sorts of [ __ ]
and it was pouring rain outside and i
had to take the biggest [ __ ]
so my brother had this big slurpee cup
i'm like i ain't going out in the rain
he's like you're not [ __ ] him like
yes i am so i went in the back of the
truck
dude you don't realize how much [ __ ] can
fill up a slurpee cup
oh dude i dropped i dropped a hot coil
in that thing
my brother could not stop gagging and
what do you think that does for you
brendan
oh i got fired
i think that was the cherry on the on
the on the cake where they're like we
just got to get rid of you doug it's
cherry on sunday
well no i like cake i don't like sundaes
somebody's been
putting cherries on random foods
the cherry on the steak i think it's
always the last thing no matter what
yeah it's always the last that's the
cherry on the hot dog
that works too dog so now what happened
to it did you
did you i got fired well the final thing
was we hated our boss this dude matt
he's a piece of [ __ ]
and he smoked cigarettes all the time so
and he left his cigarettes out one day
because he had to go like talk to
somebody
so i took the cigarettes and everyone's
like what are you gonna do i put in my
butt hole
so his cigarette's what this part he was
smoking up has [ __ ] on him
so he came back started smoking the
cigarettes we all started laughing
and i think that was the final cherry on
the steak
i have so many questions i was like 15.
like 15. yeah we got why was there still
[ __ ] on your butthole did you not clean
it properly i went deep in there dog
oh gosh that's so nice so shout out to
all seasons in denmark colorado they're
still they're family operated
okay okay i have to confess something
too now
oh god one time in grade school we peed
in water guns and we sprayed them on the
girls in our class we were in like third
grade i feel really bad about it those
are
those are kelly superstars super suckers
theo's a shame yeah what'd you oh my bad
to you i didn't break the law and open
up
federal mail [ __ ] we're all
sharing you're gonna
judge me dude i'm not this guy was mean
to us
i'm praying for you right now
[Laughter]
i'll take all the help i can get yeah
you're getting some right now dude
i am asking for help for you man y'all
nasty
yes that's what i want to say chappelle
yeah y'all never did anything like not
you cat y'all y'all never did anything
like that
one time my homie pissed in a water
balloon threw it on my face yeah
hell yeah and then uh one time a friend
slapped dog [ __ ] on my
face i was really drunk southern comfort
night
what yeah what's comfortable about that
that ain't something they're in there
that's mitt that's
that's y'all never did anything get back
at bosses or anything nobody ever change
you like
[ __ ] growing up i'm a nice guy too but i
don't need to
i don't need to get them back it'll
happen for them i also don't need to use
poop out of my body to prove my point
you know like i will just uh you can
poop into the bathroom and then go prove
your point separately
chin you never do anything not like that
but i did something that
i feel terrible about oh let's hear it
tell us about that jen
so my parents obviously are very very
strict right korean parents
yeah wow so me me and my brother and my
best friend cam
we were at a place called westminster
mall we got into a fight
and then the car drove up next to us and
shot at us
so went through our car the one bullet
got stuck
right where my door was at but luckily
didn't go through otherwise
it hit my neck the other one went
through the back seat
went under the car and all that stuff so
me and my brother were freaking out my
dad's gonna find out
so me my brother and another friend went
driving around
at nighttime and we stole like a piece
of a car that looks like ours
so you can't see the bullet you know you
know that little the thing the rubber
rock yeah yeah so we just drove around
look for a similar car the rubber siding
yeah we just jacked it and then put it
on our car
damn check it out you feel bad about
that because i told you
i stole someone's being asian let's
don't forget they also put a huge
spoiler on the back of the car for no
reason i did too
they're like hey the car got shot a few
times this is a great time to add an
even bigger sport
that's all let's also add this exhaust
system that's not the solution it's just
it's just looks oh it's just oh i
thought there was something like illegal
about that
no you can always go on i'm sorry no
good
the exhaust can be illegal damn chin one
up my story like a [ __ ] oh
chin got shot out driving i don't know
right yeah i just put
someone's cigarettes in my butt
well that's the thing wait why were they
shooting at you because they thought we
were gangsters and we didn't
act like you know we weren't gangsters
we were just like what are you gonna do
yeah and this was the 90s man people
shooted asians all the time back then
the l.a riots but i'll say this though
you can tell an asian kid shame by this
inversely by the size of the spoiler on
their car i feel like
i feel like it's directly how is that
not a chart
it's true how big's your fin yeah how
big's your fin huh
how big is your fin how big is your sin
there you go how big you're saying nick
you got nothing i feel like you put some
stuff up your butt
water gun why are you guys disgusting
there's no
no poo stuff but i told you super
soakers super super yeah okay
all right that's pretty sorry charlie
sorry colleen did you say anything or
not
uh no i was never into stuff like that
but i went to
school with a girl who used to like when
she got mad at other girls in the locker
room she would take out like a used
tampon and chase girls around
oh yeah oh yeah everyone was afraid of
her of course
her name was diane she's just [ __ ]
dead she would like
take out a tampon after p.e she'd walk
out and suddenly
just see her like yeah it's like while
everyone was changing
like the one girl who was bullying that
hot one bro right after p.e
she turned into a track star with that
tampon in her hand is she hot
no regular home is she hot you pervert
she's under age
well no not if you're both 12 dog
yeah how old were you uh i was like 15
yeah she was not hot
if you're all 15 it's all good where'd
she end up we're not 15 right now oh you
don't know where she's at i don't know
where she's at probably not doing it
well she's listening
i hope you do shout out to you diane i
hope you're doing better i had a good
story i was going to share
it's about you breaking the law again
and judging me
interlocking your hands with other dudes
while you're taking [ __ ]
probably it was a game you were doing
this game
bro y'all don't have any fun man smoke
my gnats
bro how does someone get comfortable
enough
to poop in that situation though well
that was the thing and they had a clock
you were on a time
how much time did you have yeah like a
minute oh wow
that's a quick that's disgusting so yeah
yeah it was like a real
you know kind of real russian roulette
yeah i guess that's something different
yeah it was just a real
you know who's who he's like a real
who's who of the neighborhood
your games are gay
bro most games kids play are freaking
gay dude
you go high tomorrow i'm gonna come find
you we're both men we're both boys
that's gay all the time
yeah hey i'm gonna touch you and run off
that's gay tag
yeah freeze tag kick a can was pretty
good game
let's kick the can it's where you put a
can somewhere
and then somebody's supposed to guard it
what do you all know it or something do
i know
i've i've heard of it but i've never
really understood it i thought it was a
bigger speech
[Laughter]
yeah we didn't play kick the king
because we had balls so we'd like play
kickball you know
dude oh my bad guy who's defecating in a
slurpee cup
right while he's on the clock yeah and i
got fired for it dude i get punished
i'm sorry bro oh you didn't do it
anymore after that oh you got fired
i'm giving you no i'm just saying like
to anyone else no dude i will tell you
this story so we had no one else was
mean to me
we had a guy who uh
got like insecure about the size of his
wiener you know standard
and so this boy they called him the
thrill you know
and uh because his name was will so they
call him willa thrill that's why
they didn't just call him the thrill but
um
so anyway one time in the bathroom he
defecated into his hand
you know like a long you know slice
[Laughter]
and then he brought put that like in
front of his
like coming out of his hand as if that
and try to tell people that that was his
penis
hilarious he's like oh yeah i got a big
penis you know
and everybody's like you're nuts you're
crazy man that's duty
yeah that's poop that's gross and that
was disgusting and that was about his
package
to bring it back to the theme of the
episode yeah
so anyway man that dude was always fake
dickin
he was always fake dick and whatever
what's aj hawk got for us what's this
yo theo yo brandon what's up uh ian
brown here i'm in austin texas
delivering pizza
actually at my job um originally from
houston texas
what's up gang gang h-town baby
so this [ __ ] here just took me two
dollars
83 cents on a 40 ticket um i want to
know what you guys think
um about tipping over 20
do you do it is it too much do you not
uh
my opinion is you should always tip over
20 um i also want to know what cap
thinks about my hair is it too long do i
have a chance
[Laughter]
for the girls i don't know tell me what
to do
love you guys gang gang buzz buzz is it
how what do you think of his haircat
he has beautiful hair is it too long
though uh
it is a little long but i don't really
mind it he just has really nice hair
he's a regular man this guy yeah how
tall
[Laughter]
as far as tipping i believe in over 20
if they do the job sometimes postmates
like your food's on its way and like oh
sorry you have to do another delivery
yeah
and whatever you order is going to come
30 minutes later i'm like oh you just
[ __ ] up you ain't getting your tip now
yeah
and sometimes it'll be like hunt it'll
be like honduras on his way you know and
then it'll be like
hondura has measles you know yeah loses
three days and then it's like oh hondura
has dysentery that
we have to bury somebody in his group
and you're like is this oregon trail
i thought this was postmates have you
ever had it to where
it tells you what car they're coming in
yep and then they show up on a bike
yeah yeah bruh i'm like how does that
happen they had a fella that came to me
one night dude and he's like man i gotta
come chill out man can i come in i gotta
go
[Laughter]
did he come in and chill out no no no i
went because he got him a cup of water
and told him just leave the cup i mean i
respect his hustle and stuff but
yeah he was on a uh he was on a
bird on a bird scooter and it took
forever
no if it takes too long i know it's up
the stream like you're [ __ ] man
i can't give you a good tip i can't give
you get if it if you're bullshitting
can't give you a good tip man
dude i'll tip this guy do we have this
guy's information nick yes
i'm gonna send him a hundred bucks let
me send my hundred dollars oh nice nice
i'll se i'll throw that in there too
damn chappelle
salary i i
like to tip well i like yeah me too if
they're good but
i'm just not doing for everyone if
you're shitty you ain't getting that
salty tip i'll tell
you i'll tip 200 i'll i'll do you i'll
oh one of them
i went up in you i'm just saying i will
do your hundred you keep your money
ah so
chappelle was immediately regretting
that
i shouldn't have said that i was doing
it for the show all right
oh you were doing it to be kind man so
ever since he said he was a pretty crier
last week
bill's trying to [ __ ]
it was weird basically so i'm paying you
a hundred dollars not to try to
this episode is disgusting
this is disgusting what do you have nick
what do you hold on what do you got nick
dude this guy obviously has been up for
a couple days right here
yeah you okay obviously randy quade's
son
hold on i feel so bad i'm already
judging this guy uh before he's even up
here
that that might be a good pick though
randy quaid son
and randy creators had a birthday too
actually who's birthday
yup he does
that's brennan's really art really doing
that yeah um
what's he saying oh this episode is
disgusting
that's what i was what up brandon theo
coming to you from jackson tennessee on
that delivery truck
picking up them dirty laundries dropping
off them clean rags
got a king of the stinger for you gas
station food
king it or stinging snicker bars hitter
or big mac
quitter gang gang buzz buzz
if you don't have to worry about a diet
i don't mind that convenience store
food man you get the nachos you get that
weird
suspect chili on top of them nachos yeah
suspect
here here's here's what's wrong
[Laughter]
stay awake dude here's something real
fast
i used to open up a bag of doritos and
then put in the
hot nacho cheese yeah i do that with hot
cheetos you ain't
[ __ ] bro yeah that's oh that's the og
nothing but it's so nice what y'all do
then you wash it down with a nice
routine you get like the hot cheetos or
doritos
and you go to that cheese machine that's
for the for the nacho cheese
yeah you put them in that uh open up the
bag boom get that cheese what are y'all
doing
science at the gas station you guys are
out of here
usually i'd like what do you want for
the cheese like oh you got a dog there's
charged me for the chips
oh wow i put a little chili on there too
like a frito
see i used to know i had a dude that
used to work about a 7-11 by me and he
would text me and let me know whenever
they put the fresh franks up there on
the grill because some
on those rollers oh yeah you now they
got the pizza rollers on there too which
are [ __ ] fires
the taquitos are pretty good too well no
that's really good but
uh you got this thing back home called
quick trip they got real good guys
that's a gas station quick trip
started la crosse wisconsin baby hell
yeah
they employ like a third of the state
wow really
not a third of the state but they they
employ a lot of people uh they're
they're a great company like
great great employment benefits all that
like wow
yeah they take care of them i thought of
when i was growing up getting a job at
quick trip is unattainable
wow
[Laughter]
what is this guy asking us about dirty
laundry if you can wear a nice shirt to
a gas station
food gas station food basically i dig it
i dig it yes that's a great guy to know
the guy tipping you off about the fresh
dogs
oh dude he would hit me up hey hey you
know we just put them all just put them
on
cruise on down there ain't nothing like
a fresh dog oh yeah i'll and i like them
the problem is you get the ones that
have been out there three days
four days they're just percolating on
those on those rollers they sweat oh
they're sitting sideways dude
you know sideways yeah you'd see them
sweating they look all wrinkly
yeah and they put like almost one i
would have an spf on it you're like how
long is this thing
someone sometimes they have them chatter
dogs too the big fat juicy chatter dies
that are rotating
come on nice
perfect i don't want somebody injecting
cheddar into the middle of a dog
yeah start living dog you'll quit
[ __ ] interlocking fingers with your
friend and [ __ ] in pools and start
living
dude that was dirty ernie that was the
game you delinquent what's this
so this isn't uh delivery man but this
is someone who delivers people
i one time got this uber driver shelly
uh this is this is her
that's shelley that's shelley represent
shelly uh it's just kind of a rip my
drip i guess i didn't get in the car i
cancelled but
she was a 4.8 that's why i cancelled oh
wow
that's low any anything out of five yeah
anything under 4.85
you're gonna you're gonna have some
problems it'll the car will smell
they'll be too chatty
you want 4.9 or above i take it every
every day
you take uber every day yeah yeah all
right shouts out yeah
she put in her uber driver bio
that she is a certified massage
therapist dog she's gonna give you a
ride
yeah loves meeting people
at the same time or once you get to your
destination though yeah
or does she start off with it i'm sure
the sales pitch begins the second you
close that door
welcome no it seems exhausting would you
do it theo
did you get in there get a massage in a
car i've done it before but i was young
you know you drove a taxi well the taxi
driver got
whatever you got yeah i got some oral
sex one time
so i've definitely commandeered some
vehicles where sex was occurring but
i don't know man i'm good kind of yeah
you're probably smart nick yeah i just
can't believe everybody's been talking
about poop so much
we'll start with you and your friends
interlocking fingers no that's not how
it started
i think so and then i ran from there no
someone else no the man
said would you poop somewhere didn't oh
that's right oh yeah yeah and then i
brought up the all-season story when i
got fired
yeah and then you took it from there
what else you got nick gross
hey fellas it's your boy and brown from
southeast idaho
i just uh won another battle against
fedex in this never-ending delivery war
thank god the weather's cooling down
because we know they can't handle the
heat
that's hilarious yeah shout out to that
guy it's tough who do you roll with on
that if you go
fedex or you go ups there ain't nothing
better when ups pulls up
you've been waiting for a package yeah
the dude jumps out there
brown fit it's sick now i will say this
the fedex guy
ups the ups guys are more old-school
they're more like
jack the calf muscles on the ups guy
in the brown shorts yeah yeah and they
got the combat boots on
even the hands you can even hear the
muscle working through the pants yeah
it's cause they're carrying them big
loads
just say boxes man let's say the
carrying boxes stuff the kind of stuff
they are stronger men because they have
good
long-term benefits dental you'll see the
man got clean teethy smiles that you
show your clean ones you know
they've got good stuff at ups he's doing
he gets off of work they gotta wait some
of them to have weight
weight gym at the same ups center you
could do the weights right there if you
want
amazon always seems stressed out because
i think they deliver so many [ __ ]
packages they kind of just throw things
and
jump back in amazon and amazon knows
they're about they're you know
seconds away from losing their job to a
drone you know
my mom delivers for amazon she's always
cursing asking me about drones do i know
anything about new drones
[Laughter]
and i'm like mom yeah ups some real real
ass dudes man
yeah they'll drop off your package wanna
do a podcast with you oh ups is for real
dude real jesus and that dolly they get
the dolly out yeah
so what is fed fedex is a little bit
more like nouveau kind of has kind of a
french vibe got a sign for it
yeah hey hey fedex is fancy products a
little fancier i think
was it fedex or uh ups on castaway
someone passed fedex that's right now i
like dhl man
and i invested in their stock years ago
and lost a lot of money but
i thought dhl was going to be that big
hitter when they tried to go
international
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] now what's
happening in the in the latino community
or the chinese community
dhl is uh big if you go if you uh order
[ __ ] from china
i know a lot of usps uh workers are
filipino mm-hmm
you know that yeah and that is beautiful
so if you have karaoke
yeah yeah then drop off a package
against a bruno mars
that's a good time why they [ __ ] with
karaoke so now who does the black
community trust the most when it comes
to these delivery companies
usps oh golden brown huh
i don't know what can brown do for you
dog
oh well who do you ship with who knows i
always go to fedex because it's right by
my house
oh okay so proximity yeah that's why i
go out i don't know whether i don't know
where the hell
i like ups because they get them
cardboard boxes in there too yeah me too
you go in there you know they're trying
to compete with the man
amazon trying to take the world over you
you ups still doing the damn thing this
is the us market
yeah holy [ __ ] ups dominates
oh wow
ups over 50 the fedex cracking hard
brought about 30
if you want to uh ship anything under 13
ounces or under usps is the cheapest
it'll it'll take you a week like you
said
yeah for drugs that dhl be sending them
drugs
what is dhl they're yellow and red
and they deliver packages beautiful oh
yes yes yep
beautiful units beautiful man suspect
though
dhl baby they're yeah you always see
their
yep they're planes well i always thought
we should have fedex the airline like
why can't
why can a package be guaranteed to be
there tomorrow but i can't you know
mm-hmm
because sometimes you get your flight
gets canceled whatever but your box
still gets there you're like how what is
it going on
um if fedex did air human
i think that's called jetblue i'd fly
fedex though i think it's called spirit
airlines
no dude that spirit i saw two dogs fight
on the spirit one
two two people had dogs get what you pay
for yeah
what's this rick brendan theo day one
listener here hey
quick one that bag lunch
king of their stinging gang gang buzz
buzz oh
dude king it bro cause you can put any
snack you want
you know that nice treats waiting for
you on your break i like to put a little
fruit by the foot
maybe some [ __ ] teddy grams
and you know they're waiting for you
yeah i like maybe get that oatmeal
sandwich
my fave i like getting a little sandwich
boy
cut it in half what makes me mad is if
my sandwich in that and the lunch isn't
cut in half dude i'll lose my damn
mind bro i'll murder a [ __ ] oh i
will quit the job and hit somebody with
my truck in the afternoon [ __ ] yeah dog
i need my [ __ ] cut you cut it diagonally
go down the middle yeah
and oh i'll cut it diagonally yeah me
too i want my i want that
i want that rectangle yeah it's nerd
alert if you cut down the middle that's
straight up nerd alert bro
i like a nice [ __ ] sandwich two
pieces of white bread
you feel me this wheat [ __ ] white bread
thick
cheese thick meat and then i like little
lay's potato chips
maybe i'll wash it down with the capri
sun and i got that little debbie's
waiting for me on the side now what gets
sticky with me is if you get tomatoes on
there because by the
time lunch comes around they're sweating
they're sweating they sweat through
the bread and it gets yeah it gets a
little weird in there
so what you do you put them on the side
dog you put them inside their own little
package
they take them out you put them on the
sandwich that might be it
now what get me as a child you
accidentally spill your kool-aid your
thermos would spill over in your lunch
and then you got to eat the grape
you know grape grape meat sandwich yeah
yeah yeah
that [ __ ] is tie-dye yeah [ __ ]
dripping and you gotta
you know it's actually pretty nice
though
it's disgusting i didn't mind it like
what's this little thought talking about
well i actually i want to see what you
guys think of this
it's a new take on the pb j sandwich
i thought it was pretty genius
oh so every bite is different uh
what's going on there's that cream
cheese honey you got the rose
jam honey marshmallow are the rose and
then the columns are crunchy
nutella and creamy so every bite you
take is a different combination
that sounds fantastic i
real quick you crunch your creamy dog
i'll go crunchy brother
i can't get any more crunchy yeah i want
them crunchier the better yeah i want to
feel them nuts in my mouth
i'm talking about peanut butter this
whole thing is disgusting man
damn i can't go crunchy without turning
gay i mean it's just
as every time i turn around there's just
somebody's you know
there's poops there's penises
you have a sign that says smoke my natch
yeah and i mean it and you pointed that
dude
[Laughter]
i mean it bro okay i will light up a
sweet bowl of monash dog
for any of you freaking perverts dude
speak up
chin huh [ __ ] jesus
talk about getting lunch right now lunch
you made me super hungry
working for the irs so you started
[ __ ] eating
right now what are you eating chin yeah
what is it
it's vietnamese are you eating chocolate
you eating cheese on the job
no it's food it's jack it's vinegary
sausage meat
that stinks too bag sauce poor nick
i know
if you bust out snack did you bring
enough for everybody yeah yeah
bring enough for everybody girlfriend
has been to me so he's used to that
yeah yeah i've had some for for sure
before i had some kind of live duck or
it wasn't live but it was
the snail uh no it was an egg it was
like a it was like a chicken in there
but it was like fully full
with the blue egg yeah yeah yeah yeah
that shit's [ __ ] dude
yeah i ate the whole thing it was in
front of her family i had to
that's disgusting that's a keeper how'd
it go uh keeper nick
it was it was all right i it honestly it
just tasted like a seasoned deviled egg
but like if you look visually if you
looked
super heavy on the devil some poor
little chicken
let's listen to this thought it says yes
uh just not all
delivery men are that altruistic this is
evidently a report
on every [ __ ] time damn no i'm hungry
yeah me too i wish i had that [ __ ]
snitch
what a snitch no i think it's because
it's his business and he's getting bad
reviews because the food is the delivery
he owns he's he's missed her postmate no
i think it's like his restaurant that
someone's ordering from they think they
forgot
listen man like i said i wore
chick-fil-a the other week half my
[ __ ] waffle fries were
gone i mean i did nothing good for you
dude get you some fries you're working
hard out there go ahead and
sip on my [ __ ] diet dr pepper dog
don't touch those 12-piece nuggets
because we're not problems
y'all got small nuggets at chick-fil-a
though that's why i like that
small but packed with flavors y'all got
them small ass
what's your go-to order that's chicka
[ __ ] i get a [ __ ] nugget's too small
one of those nuggets is three mcdonald's
nuggets now come on five chicken flayers
up
i get a 12 i get a 12 piece nugget if
i'm feeling fat i'll get the 30
piece i get two sandwiches one spicy one
regular
a diet dr pepper an extra large waffle
fry
you can you can finish that yeah
chappelle damn do you put your waffle
fries on the sandwich
never a goddamn american yeah
but you'll eat a sandwich that has
kool-aid on it well
that happens by mistake yeah and that's
the most japanese thing you can do dude
i feel like
kool-aid soaked sandwiches that tie-dye
hitter yeah
i feel like a really um far east i'm
[ __ ] starving i know
i didn't eat breakfast anyway dude me
neither dude smoke my [ __ ] natch
oh did you see this lady uh she
dipped her chicken tender into her soda
and she got caught on camera
oh i wonder why she did that i don't
know but i
guarantee you she
performs oral sex dude
and well too i don't know about well do
but anybody who's with
if somebody is willing to uh to dip a
chicken tender into
a soda yeah you could probably convince
them to experiment with your own wiener
i bet
you right you're disgusting doug this
whole episode you've been disgusting
i know i'm sorry it's okay i don't know
what happened
is that it that's it that's it man john
smoked my natch we started with elton
john
i'll be in uh phoenix stand up live
early november i think first week in
november
and then third week in november i'm in
nashville in this boys part of town
and tell your stupid ass team to get
ready cause i'm throwing [ __ ] heat yo
are you yeah i'm gonna wear my own
jersey and strike out your entire stupid
team
oh you mean our softball squad yep we
have our first game coming up
good luck oh good luck thank you very
much it's against
a printing company
so we'll see what these fishing mffers
have in store for them and
send in your cats walk submissions
wearing the king and the sting merch
uh the funnier the better get your foot
yeah get your modeling on man
get a catwalk going yeah yeah and we'll
add some audio to it and stuff we'll
that we'll add audio to it so we just
want to see the modeling
but yeah we're playing dominic's
printing [ __ ] what's up dominick's
praying let him know some italian outfit
i'm sure
do drug testing [ __ ] so the thing is
when you're pitching to italians the
strike zone's smaller
so you got to know what you're doing you
know bring the heat doug wish you the
best
we'll do well i think we'll room for you
back here
yeah thank you i appreciate that good
thank you guys you bet
i'll send some updates if i can start
if you're struggling for the dollar
shave club
calories wants his beard back enough is
enough
elise theo's hairstyle is consistent
looking like danny boone from a distance
wouldn't want to scare you cause your
hair just might jump
off
[Music]
hey brenden will you share your energy
drink
[Music]
you should change your name from streaks
to kink and the stink
i know you're used
do you think
[Music]
do you accept paypal or transfer wise
[Music]
is
[Music]
is touching each other's
[Music]
knees
me